well today 8 news now kicks off our
great food drive and you can donate at
any Smiths around the valley to help
project 150 and homeless teens during
the holiday season project 150 feeds
homeless teens all year round our John
langler and Candace Charles live at The
Smiths in Sky Canyon in the Northwest
Valley this morning with all the details
on how you can help out good morning you
two
Good morning Sherry how you doing good
morning folks yeah glad you guys are up
with us this morning right so here we
are it's the project 150 benefit here
with the great food drive 8 news now
this stuff box is still empty it's too
empty candles here's one you can bring
something like this or you can bring one
of my favorites some Cheez-Its or I
guess Annie's crackers right yes yes
quick and simple you guys can come on to
the store do some shopping drop a few
items in to help out some of our youth
in our community this is every Smith's
in the valley oh what is it about 40
stores I guess it is around southern
Nevada where you can help just drop off
while you're going grocery shopping pick
up something extra while you're at the
checkout counter plop it into one of our
boxes here it'll go to a great cause one
in six teenagers all across the state
are struggling with Hunger right now and
the need is so enormous during the
holiday season so how about if you can
and donate some food for project 150.
yes you will help them replenish their
Pantry which they've actually gone ahead
and start to empty out because they've
been able to help out some of the kids
during the holidays so they need your
help to fill out that Pantry once again
again you can go to any of the Smiths
throughout the state to go ahead and you
know donate it's pretty simple we'll be
here all morning long we're going to be
here all day long in fact the evening
crew will be here as well so come say hi
to us but more importantly make sure you
donate to project 150 and the great food
drive starting this morning yes starting
this morning goes all the way December
2nd plenty of time for you guys come on
down here and donate of course John yes
we're gonna have a great time down here
so come on down here and visit us the
store is opening soon yeah we're back to
you in the studio